with the economy up Isis pummeled
criminals deported 12 appellate judges
confirmed regulation slashed and
consumer confidence high one would think
that the president's poll numbers would
be above 50 well they're not of course
the usual suspects in the media you know
those same people who erroneously relied
on polls in 2016 they're eager to hype
the bad Trump news today we have a
president with sinking approval ratings
an unpopular piece of legislation the
tax bill supported by just one party
twenty four percent approval rating
among women I've never seen a number
that low the president's approval rating
has fallen to thirty five percent that's
a new low in our CNN polling that is
something that is a record low for every
president dating back to Eisenhower well
all things considered it is better to be
a popular president rather than an
unpopular one
remember when Bush's popularity began to
take a nosedive in 2005 because of the
Iraq war and his response to Hurricane
Katrina that was brutal well back then W
dismissed the reports of his low
standing with the public
he didn't fret much or do much about it
then you remember the Democrats went on
to win the House the Senate and 36
governorships across America then what
happened two years later with the
economy and tatters Bush's numbers
cratered and Barack Obama was elected
now back to Trump he is a strong
populist core and so of course he wants
to be popular and he understandably gets
frustrated when his message doesn't seem
to be breaking through and truth be told
the president has made some missteps
he's not perfect and of course the media
pounced on them the bungled travel ban
the firing of Jim Comey and the decision
probably to get involved in that Alabama
Senate race at all and then of course
Democrats have harped on the phony
Russian collusion story for a year and
this all had a cumulative effect on the
public psyche but now with the economy
poised to roar in 2018 liberals and
their lap dogs and the press need a
fresh Nair
to freshen it up inciting the ROI more
loss in Alabama and Gillespie's in
Virginia the New York Times and other
outlets are reporting that suburban
women even those who voted for Trump are
turning on him well they're supposed to
be I guess put off by his brash neces
bluntness his tweet storms and now well
say the CNN Trump bashers his lack of
empathy it's about expressing normal
human emotion it's about expressing
condolences he doesn't do that first
first he exploits it for political
purposes this administration writ large
is engaged in a larger game of trying to
contain the president's worst impulses I
hear people say even diehard Trump
people is we want humanity you know what
no politician can win without empathy he
won anyway
even with numbers that suggested people
saying we don't think he understands
people I guess is it catching up with
him now yes I think the answer you can't
learn empathy you can't learn empathy
well I disagree with these clowns and
here's why maybe the president is
sharing his empathy in a different way
and I'd argue that in his first year
president Trump has shown empathy for
the people of this country in action if
not in words at all the times think
about his deep feeling for the working
people the middle-class Americans of
faith and job creators entrepreneurs
it's all evident in his policies so if
ridding the suburbs of ms-13 lowering
taxes and improving school choice isn't
showing empathy for the middle class
then what is it if the massive
deregulation and trade policies that are
spurring job creation and driving the
economy isn't showing empathy for the
worker then what is it and I'll say if
driving black unemployment to an
all-time low
and laboring to get drugs off the
streets isn't showing empathy to the
african-american community then what is
it to President Trump I say the
following you've accomplished so much
this year but you're not gonna ever get
the press on your side they're not going
to give you credit but I'll tell you
this more
voters can and will be on your side with
maybe just a few tweaks a few modest
changes perhaps the time has come to put
aside a few of the Twitter battles
I like the tweets but not all of them
and now it's time to humanize the agenda
you've been fighting for you see your
predecessors Barack Obama and Bill
Clinton were masterful of motors in
chief they could turn on the chair
machine and them like that they could
bear hug at the drop of a hat and while
they were often all emotion they were at
the same time often no action I say it's
possible to do both and I was thinking
today about that incredible event that
you held mr. president in August of 2016
with angel families who had lost loved
ones at the hands of illegal aliens it's
an important reminder of how policy and
empathy can align and when you listen
and teach nobody does it better and if
that's not empathy empathy what is it
then what hurricane Harvey struck
Houston and he visited the shelter
housing flood victims it was powerful if
that's not what empathy what is I like
seeing you out among the people I like
seeing you with children the elderly
factory workers volunteers you can be
really charming and you can be really
warm in person and it's time to let more
Americans see that my radio listeners
today offered their own advice for what
you should do before the midterms and
one suggested a twice monthly fireside
chat where you explain important
policies to voters and introduce them to
the people who will be impacted
positively by those policies I think
it's a good idea and it's great politics
as well and I also like the fact that
you deliver your message directly in
that scenario with or without the
media's coverage of it I say it's now
time to govern all the people to take
your agenda to the inner city to
suburbia to the churches into the areas
of the country that have been somewhat
or really unreceptive to the populist
conservative message it's hard
to be a national party isn't it when
every presidential election cycle we
write off California and New York right
off the bat and there's no reason the
Democrat should have a monopoly on the
coast that's absurd just go and try
there give it an effort and at times
just your presence just showing up and
listening can be the most powerful
action of all and I say if that is an
empathy and a winning strategy what is
and that's the angle